y con él vamos a hablar de la carrera
contrarreloj de alemania para llevar
ante la justicia los últimos criminales
nazis que ya tienen más de 90 años de
edad de ello serán los últimos en
enfrentar la justicia sin embargo estos
no formaron parte del alto mando militar
de adolf hitler ni comandaron algún
escuadrón de las ss eran guardias de
seguridad
secretarias o empleados administrativos
que trabajaron en los campos de
exterminio del tercer reich y ahora más
de 75 años después del final de la
segunda guerra mundial finalmente están
enfrentando a la justicia para ello
entonces quiero saludar a marcus daniel
meier él es el analista internacional
phd docente del departamento de derecho
constitucional de la universidad
externado en colombia gracias a profesor
marcos por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 de pregunto cuál es
este objetivo de llevar a los nazis es
tan avanzada edad- a un juicio sirven
estas penas con tantos años de retraso
digamos
y es una reflexión muy común porque
obviamente no hay
peligro que conviertan estos tipos de
crímenes o tales entonces y son muy
viejos
pero yo estoy tan convencido
como los jueces también que es
importante que el estado directo
contiene a estos crímenes aunque los
acusados no son del alto mando pero más
guardianes secretarias
para dar paso a los víctimas los
víctimas sufren no solamente ellos
mismos pero también sus hijos sus nietos
esto es
establecido y bien investigado y para
ellos es importante
y el estado contiene después 70 años
estos crímenes horribles y eso es la
respuesta también yo creo el aspecto
general preventivo es importante que la
gente no piense en otros partes del
mundo en otros tiempos de portas que te
dejan escapar
si insistas en la responsabilidad de
mando pero es sino que estos crímenes si
se van a castigar y también castigar
duramente por el producto eso es otro
aspecto
ahora le pregunto a marcus por qué
digamos se ha tardado tanto estos
juicios contra estos nazis y digamos que
si puede ser debido a la avanzada edad
una condena tipo moral o si realmente
ellos teniendo en cuenta la justicia
alemana tras ser hallados culpables van
a cumplir alguna condena de cárcel oa lo
mejor casa por cárcel
pues primero obviamente una una corte lo
condena por
razones morales pero por razones legales
la jurisdicción en que quedar puramente
con las leyes aplicables
porque tuvo tanto en hay dos respuestas
los tres en esto yo creo primero hubo
los procesos ahora en los años 60 donde
los
criminales más difíciles eran condenados
pero tenemos que recordar que en estos
años durante la tierra fría
un poco interés por diferentes partes
políticos judiciales actual llenar esta
gente y unos vieron incluso como buenos
anti comunistas
y trabajando para la vuelta derecha
alemana en estos años otra cosa es el
sistema jurídico alemán ya estaba
todavía masivamente impregnado con el
primer viejos nazis
y estaban cobrando uno algo por tejiendo
uno al otro y dijeron pues esperemos y
para que mueran y para que no
produzcan una ola que eventualmente
podría amenazar a los otros los jueces
mismos
yo creo eso eran las dos razones el
dogma ticamente era difícil también
condenar a personas específicas porque
para condenar a una persona por
homicidio hay en grandes precauciones
para proteger esta persona y con razón
porque es una de estas sanciones con muy
fuertes y tienes que probar aquí persona
mataste con qué en qué tiempo en el
lugar
esto está bien en un caso específico
como sitio específico pero paraguay
genocidio eso es totalmente disfuncional
obviamente que podría decirte pues
entonces muéstrame cómo se llama cuando
corte arma y el sistema policial no
tenía las herramientas
para conducir este tipo de procesos
solamente hasta 11 años cuando en mi año
ese cambio cambio está en esta figura y
cambiaron a la figura de ayuda a
domicilio esto es es como es para
explicar son pocos ciclistas es como un
turno robas el banco pero esperas en el
carro con el carro para los criminales
eso también es culpabilidad y en este
contexto
como ayuda a crímenes que condenaron a
the jam yo a los demás obviamente mucho
demasiado tarde pero como ya expliqué
eso eran
por razones
políticos y por razones personales y
desea retraso tanto si solamente en 2011
empezó
y condenar a estos digamos de segundo
tercer rango o secretarias guardianas
con 100 años a condenar por las razones
ya expuestos ahora profesor marco que
estamos hablando de en comparación de
algunos pocos los que si realmente están
o han enfrentado la justicia no qué va a
pasar con esas personas que se quedaron
por fuera no las miles las miles de
personas que trabajaron también con los
nazis o son nazis que están por el mundo
incluso en alemania que a lo mejor no
les llegaría la justicia no sé si a lo
mejor nos puede dar algunos datos
algunas cifras y queda pasar con esas
personas
yo creo
cínicamente se hiciera de la una
solución biológica juana moría y como no
hay
responsabilidad de hijos y nietos por
sus padres por una también yo creo que
no vamos a seguir en este camino tienes
que acusar a una persona de un crimen
específico y tomarlo para coordinarlo y
eso es cada año más difícil
profesor marc uso como cree que van a
terminar estos juicios con los últimos
nazis condenados que se espera en
alemania
y yo creo por razones humanitarias no
van a ser esa sentencia en el exterior
porque con 100 años siempre pueden decir
y con una cierta justificación también
la
razón principal de que el sistema
político no es la venganza
pero pero tiene que tener algún tipo de
balance humanitaria en este contexto yo
creo se vuelven más simbólicos estos
procesos como realistas pero si son
públicos es importante para las víctimas
saber nosotros si podemos contar con
estos con esos juicios con estas
condenas para nuestras familias y
también los los como he dicho los
dos
hijos los esto es importante para ellos
esto es también investigado que si sana
esos horribles
heridas y por eso es importante y no es
importante este aspecto si miran claro
dos accesos cinco andenes